on sera tous comme chaque semaine france
info et l'ina vous offre un voyage dans
le temps à travers les archives de la
télévision pour mieux comprendre
l'actualité contemporaine vous regardez
l'inattendu et vous êtes les bienvenus
là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup de jeunes apprennent
à tricoter à votre place je la ramène un
peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
ce qu'il vous manque qu'une seule chose
un tout petit détail
le fonds fait les valises à paris de ce
qui lui arrive à la beuze à mes côtés
géraldine corner lavaud et tarik qu'aldi
journaliste à la rédaction de l'ina
bonjour
bonne année à vous également alors vous
avez sélectionné deux archives qui
trouve un écho particulier dans cette
actualité un géraldine on revient avec
vous sur l'initiative du gouvernement
délire au hasard trente cinq citoyens
pour faire remonter les doutes qu'il y
en a face au vaccin contre le commis 19
oui et des doutes un lien il y en a et
c'est pour ça que manuel macron veut
mettre en place un conseil citoyen le
but donc vous l'avez bien réconcilier
les français avec le vaccin
mais le but ultime c'est bien évidemment
de convaincre un les plus rassuré
rassurer alors moi ça m'a fait penser à
une période c'est à la situation en 2009
souvenez vous c'était à ce moment-là
l'épidémie de grippe a est en novembre
le 12 novembre 2009 exactement 1060
centres de vaccination ouvraient leurs
portes ouvraient leurs portes mais c'est
un peu c'est un peu un bide n'y avait
pas une grosse affluence
alors du coup roselyne bachelot à
l'époque ministre de la santé
n'hésitez pas à donner de sa personne
cette journée est aussi un test car chez
le personnel meetic médicale en tout cas
ce vaccin suscite une grande méfiance
seuls 10% accepter l'injection c'est
sûrement pour cette raison que roselyne
bachelot est allé se faire vacciner il y
à quelques minutes dans un centre du
xivème arrondissement à paris vous la
découvrirez sur cette image on voit même
la piqûre fait à la ministre de la santé
reste à savoir si l heure
réussira à convaincre le grand public
qui n'est prêt à se faire vacciner qu'à
hauteur de 20%
d'après les tout derniers sondages alors
voilà des élus la tribu mais ce geste un
de roselyne bachelot en débardeur n'aura
pas suffi à convaincre les français pour
rappel en 2009 lors de l'épidémie de
grippe à 94 millions de vaccins avaient
été commandées pour assurer la
couverture de 75 % de français mais
bilan des courses seulement 8% des
français avait accepté d'être vaccinés
on effondré que les français soient un
petit peu plus nombreux pour enrayer la
progression du coc vidal en route à
risque qui vous interpeller c'est un
article sur notre site france tv infos
sur les punitions infligées aux enfants
oui ah le voilà cet article a grondé
punir ou frapper son enfant en fait il
ya beaucoup de parents comme ça qu'ils
témoignent ils se demandent comment
arrêter à ces pratiques qu'on appelle
des violences et éducative ordinaire
alors tout ça on le sait il ya eu du
changement dans les foyers français on
va le voir avec une archive de 1980
c'est jean claude bourret qui nous
explique sa dont son jt à l'époque et
les enfants qui ne seront pas ça je
viens de recevoir des gifles s'il faut
en croire notre confrère france soir qui
a fait un sondage sondage ifop pour
savoir comment les françaises et les
français corriger leurs enfants alors
côté bien c'est très intéressant
il ya 50 % des parents qui disent que
pour corriger leurs enfants il donne une
gifle 44% qui préfèrent la fessée et 8%
mais oui le martinet la ceinture ça fait
très mal ou la badine alors quelle est
la fréquence de ces punitions au moins
une fois par semaine ça c'est
intéressant au moins une fois par
semaine une gifle et 26%
une fessée 36% un coup de martinez ou de
ceinture 28%
voilà les autres iront voir le dessin
animé voilà ça c'était bien mais 40 ans
elle et martine et les gifler compagnie
autrique géraldine qui va bientôt
accoucher bien noté les résultats de
celle géraldine que les
violence corporels sur les enfants sont
punis par la loi depuis 2010 9 quand
même note merci dans les calanques ça
c'était pour l'actualité de la semaine
mais que s'est il passé le 6 janvier à
travers le temps regardez c'est le
zapping de l'ina et ça s'est passé ainsi
janvier je souhaite que le spectacle de
nos origines a toujours présente et de
temps de foyers encore sans abri écarte
les égoïsmes aveugle trop nombreux
en attendant si vous voulez bien
antenne 2
comanche
c'est là c'est la troisième chaîne enfin
je crois que c'est la troisième chaîne
c'est pour la troisième chaîne c'est fou
ce qu'ils arrivent à faire le progrès le
programme est une chose formidable
il est créé un institut de l'audiovisuel
chargé notamment de la conservation des
archives la recherche de création
audiovisuelle et de la formation
professionnelle une image qui ramène à
sa juste place
la toute puissance que l'on prête trop
souvent à la télévision regarder ces
tristes téléviseur échoués sur le sable
de l'île de ré ce matin
lieutenant-colonel stap sur un chariot
propulsé par neuf franck est atteint la
vitesse de 1017 km/heure record de
vitesse à terre et le record de force
d'accélération supporter trente cinq
fois celle de sa propre pesanteur aller
vite tout jour il évoqué lui même un
temps qui lui était compté
il n'avait que 36 ans c'était un prince
il en avait l'excès il en avait la grâce
ils en vivaient les rôles
considéré comme le meilleur trompettiste
de jazz après louis amstrong 10 a
rejoint au paradis les autres géants du
jazz avec son style original doué d'une
technique acrobatique dizzy gillespie le
révolutionnaire avait imposé le be bop
bonsoir yade
en attendant si vous le voulez bien
l'inattendu se poursuit la première
semaine de l'année
c'est le moment de présenter ses voeux
c'est aussi une période propice aux
prédictions que nous réserve la nouvelle
année que nous réserve 2021
géraldine certains diront ce ne peut pas
être pire que 2020 moi je préfère être
prudent parce que franchement au regard
de ces douze derniers mois plutôt
inattendu on peut s'attendre à tout
exactement mais on a quand même été voir
du côté des voyants et pour eux 2021 et
bien c'est mitigé super bien à partir du
second semestre pour certains encore
plus dur que 2020 aura pas le dire trop
fort trop non plus on sait pas trop et
ces articles qui font la une en ce mois
de janvier des astrologues et voyants et
bien ce n'est pas nouveau c'est pas
c'est pas nouveau on pourrait croire
qu'aujourd'hui on chercherait à se
rassurer mais non c'est une pratique qui
a des années et des années
depuis moi j'ai retrouvé dans les années
60 des journalistes qui consultent des
astrologues des médiums des mages pour
le jeu des mages
j'en ai vous allez voir il est
magnifique c'est ce qu'on appelle un
sujet marronniers qui fait du bien en
début de jt début d'année en fait donc
voilà c'est quelque chose qui revient
souvent mais là où c'est drôle c'est que
très souvent quand même les voyants ont
eu la vue trouble veut dire non si vous
lassiez regarder cet exemple ils datent
de 1968
quelles sont vos prévisions pour l'année
1968 pour l'armée une voix 1968 je vois
un début d'année
vraiment call me voyais dans les
affaires
c'est plutôt est-ce que vous avez
d'autres exemples de mauvaises
prévisions prédictions j'en ai à la
pelle mais il a fallu faire un choix
sinon on aurait fait une émission d'une
heure et demie et parce que c'est une
idée c'est nous dit on la lance comme ça
on sait par le père noël est passé mais
bon pourquoi pas donc c'était très
difficile de faire un choix mais voilà
une deuxième
une prédiction qui est tombé à côté
c'était le 31 décembre 1973 et voici les
prédictions des voyants pour l'année
politique 1974 la situation du
gouvernement en dépit des difficultés et
de la vie chère
cette situation se maintient et aucune
raison astrologique pour que des recours
des élections nous président de la
république demandera par référendum ou
peuple de france en même temps que le
renouvellement anticipé de son mandat un
régime purement présidentielle ce
référendum sera un succès pour monsieur
pompidou bon et bien raté un raté parce
qu'en avril 1974 georges pompidou décède
et donc il y aura bien des élections
anticipées organisées mais il y avait
encore mieux une petite perle pour
l'année 1974
comment seront les femmes en 1974 les
fachos
logique avec elle-même et -4 précieuse
plus reposante et apaisante
alors voyez vous un événement très
inattendu oui il a découvert que les
autres planètes sont habités à d'autres
planètes habitées pour 1974 des femmes
plus logique à elle avait peut-être
raison mais on ne sait pas encore c'est
pas encore peut-être qu'ils sont venus
parmi nous sans qu'on s'en rende compte
alors voilà fin des années 80 ces
consultations de voyance ont un peu
moins à la mode on les voit moins dans
les jt boj de mal mais pourtant il y a
quand même quelques perles dont ce match
dont je vous parlais au début c'est en
1900 il prédit l'année 1988 et on va le
voir il avait tout faux
1988 est une année essentielle puisque
pour la politique tout au moins et car
il va y avoir une élection
présidentielle alors que prévoyait bien
sûr on va voter plusieurs fois en très
peu de temps donc je vais vous donner le
quarté dans l'ordre
monsieur mitterrand ont dernièrement ne
se représente pas raymond barre et élus
mais pour des raisons de santé ne sera
plus là un an ou deux après simone veil
va lui succéder
elle ramène le mandat 5 6 ans alors
voilà en 1988 mitterrand sera réélu et
pour info un simone veil présidente
même si on l'a souhaité est peut-être
très fort on aurait bien aimé ça n'est
jamais arrivé même une femme à l'elysée
ça n'est pas encore arrivé alors voila
moi je suis pas voyante et un appel et
tarik donc je vais pas vous prédire ce
que vous réserve 2021 mais je peux vous
souhaiter une excellente année
merci arnaud géraldine et nous vous
souhaitons le meilleur en 2021 une année
qui restera gravé dans votre coeur et
dans votre mémoire puisque dans quelques
semaines votre famille va s'agrandir
voilà merci beaucoup
[Musique]
goodbye london le royaume uni a donc
quitté l'union européenne le 1er janvier
après quatre ans et demi de négociations
plutôt agitée 1 pourquoi ce divorce at
il été si long à mettre en place
on va en parler avec notre invité il est
terriblement concerné par cette affaire
puisqu'il est anglais bonjour john day
correspondant à paris du quotidien the
guardian
alors vous avez un pied à paris un autre
à londres quelques mois après l'annnonce
du breil site en 2007 vous aviez dit
sortir de l'union européenne c'est se
couper une jambe
vous êtes toujours dans le même état
d'esprit oui pour moi je vis ça vraiment
comme une sorte d'amputation je me sens
autant européen que que britannique j'ai
passé vingt cinq ans de ma vie sur le
continent comme on dit en grande
bretagne ma femme est française mais les
enfants sont nés à paris qui sont tous
les deux bilingues ils ont les deux
passeports
oui pour moi c'est une erreur historique
en tout cas c'est une histoire d'amour
plutôt compliquée qui se termine un
presque un crunch comme on dit dans leur
humiliante problème concerne angleterre
alors tu avec le divorce est difficile
mais les fiançailles et l'adhésion du
royaume uni ont pas été simple non plus
ah non c'était très très très compliqué
mais déjà avant parce que historiquement
le royaume uni était plus tourné vers
les états unis plutôt que vers les
voisins européens on va voir un petit
exemple en 1944 pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
winston churchill un look était premier
ministre était très clair à ce sujet
voilà ce qu'il disait au général de
gaulle
nous allons libérer l'europe mais c'est
parce que les américains sont avec nous
pour le faire car sachez le chaque fois
qu'il nous faudra choisir entre l'europe
et le grand large
nous choisirons le grand large alors au
début de la construction européenne là
avait la communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier est là c'est qu'un
si ma mémoire est en 1950 alors que font
les britanniques à cette époque et bien
on peut dire qu'il nomme la ceca ils la
voient d'un mauvais oeil un set cette
ébauche d'union jusqu'à ce qu'elle fasse
ses preuves économique dans les années
60 hélas le royaume uni frappe une
première fois la porte en 1963 une
seconde fois en
1967 mais la france dit non elle met son
veto c'est ainsi que l'idée de joindre
les îles britten à la communauté
économique formé par six états
continentaux soulève partout des
souhaits qui sont idéalement très
justifiées mais qu'il s'agit de savoir
si cela pourrait être actuellement fait
sans déchirer sans briser ce qui existe
si on résume c'est non on sent qu'il ya
un peu un ton condescendant à de la part
du général de gaulle est-ce que ça
présage et john elle l'est déjà des
relations tendues entre le royaume uni
et l'europe
à écouter je pense que les général de
gaulle a en fin de compte au bout de 47
ans que la grande bretagne a été membre
l'union européenne il a eu raison lui il
croyait et il a dit d'ailleurs que la
grande bretagne serait une sorte de
cheval de troie pour les intérêts
américains dans l'union européenne
il y avait aussi des problèmes il a tout
simplement dit en fait que la grande
bretagne était incompatible
de par sa culture son histoire avec
cette histoire d'intégration européenne
il y avait des otsi des détails
techniques sur notamment sur
l'agriculture britannique qui
fonctionnait de manière vraiment
complètement différente que
l'agriculture française et là quelques 2
française c'était évidemment le gros le
groupe d'intérêt du fait du général
c'était en tout cas dix ans après cette
prise de parole le royaume uni fini par
intégrer l'union européenne en 1973
dix ans d'attentes mais ça n'a pas
empêché le premier ministre edward
triste de se féliciter à l'occasion de
ses voeux aux pays à la télévision
c'est un jour historique nous avons
beaucoup de choses à partager
nous avons des problèmes en phase
lesquelles nous devons travailler en
commun que trouver des solutions
communes
mais ensemble
bah oui comme 2 j'aimerais aussi
souhaiter à chacun de vous aujourd'hui
dans ce que je peux appeler maintenant
la communauté élargie le très bon et le
très prospère et le très basses if i can
et plus values pis pour nous je ne vous
étiez plutôt jeunes à cette époque mais
vous avez un souvenir de cette
intégration à la communauté a battu
tafer c'était le 1er janvier 1973 que la
grande bretagne est entrée cette année
là c'était ma prime en premier voyage en
europe en france alors un échange
scolaire
chalon sur saône et j'ai découvert
découvert les joies de la france j'ai
découvert un pays où il existait
puisseguin sur une sorte de fromage ou
les gens aller au restaurant quand
c'était même pas l'anniversaire de maman
c'était le début d'une longue une longue
histoire d'invasions préfet manger des
grenouilles toutes n'ont pas de nom mais
c'était surtout c'était les intérêts
commerciaux
évidemment qui a pu laisser la grande
bretagne et c'était juste c'était fin à
sa charge les cinq ans a changé quoi
vous dans vos souvenirs vous étiez tout
jeune est-ce que ça quels souvenirs vous
gardez justement de ne sais pas qu'est
ce que ça change et justement au niveau
des intérêts commerciaux pas écouter
ceux qui s'est changé c'était vers la
fin des années 50 début des années 60
est allé on s'agrandit sont le commerce
entre la grande bretagne et ses
anciennes colonies
le commonwealth commencé à diminuer de
façon sérieux et c'était à la fin des
années 60 que le commerce avait contre
la grande bretagne et le continent et
l'union européenne ce a dépassé pour la
première fois le commerce avec les
anciennes colonies et c'était en fait
les entreprises les grandes entreprises
britanniques qui ont plaidé de façon
vraiment très très enthousiaste pour
l'entrée et c'était aussi l'équivalent
elle à l'époque en france du medef qui a
fait de même qui a compris que les
intérêts économiques des européens et
des des onglets était
voilà désormais ni les échanges
politiques entre le royaume uni et
l'europe et la france ont changé aussi à
cette époque
écoutez il ya toujours eu une histoire
entre la france entre la france et la
grande bretagne
ç'a toujours été un peu tout du moins on
a été pendant très très longtemps de
pays en guerre c'est l'histoire de deux
voire deux voisins qui se connaissent
peut-être un peu trop bien on l'a vu
très récemment avec l'histoire la fin
très très tendue de ces négociations sur
le break site tout de suite dès que ça a
commencé à aller mal les tabloïds
britanniques la presse britannique
commence à m voilà la responsabilité sur
la france c'est la faute à macron etc
alors tu arrives c'est les enjeux
politiques qu'en est il du côté de la
population
qu'est ce qui se passe en 1973 dans quel
état d'esprit sont les britanniques
c'est un peu mi figue mi raisin c'est un
peu partagé parce que vous l'avez dit on
est séparés par la manche la france et
le royaume uni
il ya cette séparation physique si on
peut dire il ya aussi une séparation
culturelle alors il ya ceux qui sont
très contents d'en brasser l'europe et
il ya ceux qui sont un peu plus
réticents comme un couple misteur
valaire c'est simplement voilà c'est ça
exactement va voir ce couple mister et
miss white qui nous raconte tout ça on a
l'impression que les anglais finalement
refusé un peu cette centrale marché
commun certainement
on ne veut pas dans le marché comme on
ne les anglais n'aiment pas à l'étude
car ici en longueur une certaine
indépendance on aime penser soi même
créer soi-même sa façon de vivre
ils ont l'impression que le marché
commun c'est peut-être obligés de faire
quelque chose qui ne veut pas faire oui
peut-être 8
l etat c'est une idée plus indépendants
peut-être je ne sais pas mais je crois
que c'est pas prendre tous ces propos
les polygones général tient pour les
jeunes c'est peut-être mieux qu'elle
soit dans le marché commun qu'est ce qui
a changé pour vous depuis quand les
attentats le marché commun par exemple
les prix ont tellement manqué qu on ne
peut plus avoir de beaux efforts le
matin on ne peut pas voir des collègues
la grille ou des gobelins pris lé
problème nous avons beaucoup plus de
problèmes mais je ne sais pas si c'est
la faute du marché commun mais enfin on
lui met tout sur le dos et ça me donne
l'occasion de râler c'est pas facile
pour miss white le bacon qu'avant on
voit un peu ce côté mais méfiance qui
existe depuis le début en fait est ce
que finalement ce mariage entre le
royaume uni et l'europe c'est un peu un
mariage oui pour le meilleur mais pas
pour le pire c'est tout à fait ça miss
white
elle avait tout à fait raison sur les
aspects on va dire culturel historique
géographique je veux dire il ya tant de
raisons le break site il est venu de
très loin dans l'histoire de la grande
bretagne qui en a qui n'a jamais partagé
la même histoire que le continent
surtout évidemment pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale la grande bretagne n'a
jamais été occupé leur l'union
européenne ce et est décédé dès ses
débuts vraiment un projet de paix sur un
continent qui avait été ravagé par la
guerre depuis depuis des siècles donc la
grande bataille ne voyait jamais les
mêmes intérêts c'était toujours un
projet commercial
et oui je dis alors elle a eu raison
elle avait raison sur le les aspects
culturels mais mais mais en fin de
compte 173 les onglets ils ont ils voyez
bien leur intérêt parce qu'ils ont filé
par voté à 67 % pour rester dans l'union
européenne
à l'époque en 2016 ils ont voté à 51 9 %
pour ne pas rester dans l'union
européenne
qu'est ce qui a déclenché ce
référendum qu'est ce que finalement les
britanniques au prochain en europe
écoutez c'est avec beaucoup beaucoup de
raisons comme je disais on a partagé
jamais la même vision c'était surtout
madame thatcher qui avait tu qui a été
vraiment l'un des fondateurs du marché
unique aux débuts européens commercial
très très entre deux vies l'une des
premières eurosceptique est devenu de
plus en plus eurosceptique il ya eu la
naissance du parti de lucky platanes
dépendance de du royaume uni fondé par
nigel farrage évidemment et il y avait
aussi surtout des questions
d'immigration avec l'agrandissement
l'expansion de l'union européenne vers
l'est les pays de l'est qui sont entrés
et il ya beaucoup prêtent près d'un
million de citoyens de l'europe de l'est
qui sont venus qui ont trouvé un emploi
travailleurs détachés mais surtout moi
ce que je trouve vraiment fascinant
c'est comment un pays qui un peu plus
d'un si il ya un peu plus d'un siècle
rennes ouvre là j'irai genre à un tiers
du monde la non pire britannique une
chose énorme dont l'histoire comment ce
pays là c'est toto 20 convaincus dont
l'espace de peut-être 50 ans qui vivait
sous une sorte de dictature bruxelles
oise parce que c'était ça le but du
break site où le slogan du break 6 et l
indépendance et take back contrôler
votre reprenons le contrôle sur nos lois
sur nos frontières sur notre argent
alors parmi les points sensibles de
négociation pour trouver un accord il ya
eu la pêche le partage des eaux entre
les britanniques et les européens et les
français particulièrement concernés nike
on en parle beaucoup ces derniers temps
on a beaucoup parlé avant d'arriver à un
deal mais en fait ça a toujours était un
problème parce qu'en fait dans cette eau
il ya énormément de poissons surtout
côté brillant du côté britannique
alors forcément il y a des convoitises
et quand des bateaux se croisent en mer
eh bien ils se font parfois la guerre on
va voir à l'exemple en 1992 ça faisait
l'ouverture du jt carrément
madame monsieur bonsoir certes ce n'est
pas la bataille de trafalgar
mais l'incident être même sérieux un
bâtiment de la royal navy a abordé cet
après-midi un chalutier français au
large de la cornouaille
après toute une série d'incidents qui
ont opposé pêcheurs français et
britanniques
un des chalutiers britanniques est
rentré au port ce matin mais sans ses
filets car elles ont été coupés par un
chalutier français amertume du capitaine
ils ont volontairement ignorée à la
position de mme est fier et ont
contourné le bateau est plus
délibérément coupé les fils et la
chambre des communes
le ton était vif et anti français on
reparlait de trafalgar
on a john à un accord a donc été trouvé
pour les cinq prochaines années et qui y
gagne qui y perd écoutez c'est une très
bonne question suffit peut-être de dire
que les pêcheurs britanniques ne sont
pas qu'être content du tout les pêcheurs
français plutôt qu'un pont s'est
peut-être pas bon signe pour les anglais
john et de l'est correspondant de the
guardian à paris merci mille fois pour
votre éclairage sur sur ce divorce entre
le royaume uni et l'europe et donc la
france
alors pour bien commencer l'année
l'inattendu a décidé de vous offrir
quelques postures de yoga millésime 1950
c'est un des meilleurs
il y avait à l'époque déjà des adeptes
de laruns relaxation en france regardez
les yogis sont là derrière cette porte
et ce bouddha hiératique mais peu
hindoue nec est le maître de cette
science qui par la maîtrise du corps
amène à la libération de l'esprit pur
voici tel qu'on l'enseigne sur les bords
du gange l'ase hanau posture du lion
spécialement destiné à calmer l'individu
et à refouler la coller cesana et de
l'homme à supporter la vie et l'utilité
pratique du hatha yoga n'échappera
certainement à personne
tenez cher monsieur vous qui accumule
les soucis ces tracas souvenez-vous de
lyon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà pourtant c'est pas bien de tirer
la langue
mercredi prochain juste après le journal
de 22 heures sur le canal 27 et toute la
semaine bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux
de france info et de lina émission
préparée avec les documentalistes al
delaveau et magali vers main merci à
elle et merci à vous d'être là
[Musique]